helps but when you bump into the
graphics glenn greenwald is an
independent journalist and friend of the
show you can find his work on sub stack
and we hope you will he just wrote an
amazing piece about an experience that
happened him in early march
five gunman stormed a house he was
staying at outside rio de janeiro
the gunman held greenwald in a guard
hostage for over an hour they stuck a
gun in his mouth
they broke his security guard's ribs
glendirold is the author of securing
democracy my fight for press freedom and
justice in bolsonaro's brazil that book
is out today
and glenn greenwald joins us now glenn
it's great to see you
this was a shocking story i think
everyone knows you was really stunned
to read it what happened
yeah so you know i mean i i was kind of
reluctant to write about it it happened
a month ago
you when you're a journalist you don't
really want to write about your own
problems but i was really encouraged to
by
especially journalists and friends of
mine who work on the crime beat who said
this is a really good opportunity to
convey to people especially with
skyrocketing crime rates in major
american cities
about how brutalizing and traumatizing
it can be even if
nobody ends up dead and so i decided to
tell the story it was very similar to
what you just said
um around nine o'clock at night i heard
my dogs barking incessantly i went out
to see why and
suddenly there were three men all with
guns pointed directly at me ordering me
into this room and when i went in there
they had already detained the security
guard of mine who works with me on my
security who's an off-duty police
officer
he was laying on the ground and they
were standing over him with guns pointed
at his head and i was actually very
relieved when they began demanding money
because my first thought was
this could be a politically targeted
crime we get a lot of
death threats in brazil because of my
reporting my husband's work as a
congressman
um and we didn't have a lot of valuables
there it's just kind of a farm we use on
the weekend
and and when i told them that they
didn't believe it
they kind of worked into a rage and
that's when they started becoming more
violent
beating my security guard breaking his
ribs putting the gun in my mouth
they stayed about an hour and then when
they finally left they tied our hands
together
behind our back bound our legs together
locked the door
and uh stole the car that that we had in
our driveway
so subsequent i mean after this happened
you came on the show and never mentioned
it which i find
pretty amazing so what i mean something
an experience like that has got to get
you thinking i'm not sure about what
but what did it get you thinking about i
mean people change when they go through
an event like the one you described
yeah i mean the reason i wrote about it
is because i actually read about a very
similar story of a vietnamese immigrant
fam
family in oakland who had four armed
gunmen break into their home at nine
o'clock at night when they were putting
their seven
year old daughter to bed and threatened
to shoot the daughter repeatedly and
then ransacked their house and stole
their valuables and i felt like
that story was worse and i wanted to
tell my story to encourage people to
donate money to them
so part of it is you just start
empathizing with other people who go
through it
but you also realize how fragile life is
you know it
very easily could have ended that day
and you want to maximize
the value of each day and also you know
you think about social pathologies what
is in the effect of
lockdowns and quarantines and isolation
and social distancing
not to make excuses for people who do
this but that drive people to this level
of desperation
well that's right i mean there's got to
be a people are clearly getting more
fearful neurotic less solid and grounded
psychologically
we see it all around us i'm sure you see
where you are there's got to be some
effect on the broader society of that
yeah i mean there were people who tried
warning when everyone was demanding
lockdowns in the us and the uk and
elsewhere including in brazil
look there are costs obviously to the
pandemic but there are huge costs
to shutting down the economy to
separating everybody to locking people
in their homes there's mental health
costs
there's enormous costs to putting people
out of work
to upending people's lives and it's
really kind of a taboo on being able to
weigh those costs and everyone just said
no the only thing that matters is the
coronavirus and stopping it
and i think we're going to be dealing
with the devastating effects of the
solutions to the coronavirus
for many many many years to come
did anyone catch the i should have asked
you this i'm not a very good journalist
did anyone catch the guys who did this
in my case uh they did they were stupid
they used the car that was in my
husband's name who's a congressman
to try and break into three different
stores that same night they weren't
professionals
they got caught easily and the police
apprehended them i'm happy to say in the
case in oakland though those
four men are at large and if you listen
to the seven-year-old girl talk about
how she can't sleep because she believes
they're
going to come back at any moment you get
a sense for how much things like this
deprive you of your sense of security
that's right that's exactly right glenn
greenwald i hope you'll keep writing as
much as you can you become a real force
globally thank you thank you tucker